foreign
what's the craziest drug you've ever
tried boozy I was addicted to PCP
wow
I was addicted to PCP uh
I I was going out there with man so
would you just dip the cigarettes in or
would it be yeah I dipped the cigarettes
in uh sometimes I get a fall that's
already dipped too but uh
my first time smoking was with Bushwick
Bill
doing PCP the first time we ever did PCP
was with Bushwick Bill like it was like
the second time second time
and you were and you were you were a
teenager yeah I was like doing PCP with
Bushwick Bill yeah give me the story
behind this
um we had we had a group we had a group
out our hood that was making moves uh
fall down in the tank and everybody come
[ __ ] with they big dogs everybody coming
to the city and [ __ ] with them and they
like Bush will beat Bushwick Bill in the
hood right right so we went over there
on Arizona Street and they you know they
smoking wet so you know I got in the
circle you know what I'm saying that
[ __ ] was crazy but that's that was the
most joke because I used to hallucinate
so much and well no it's crazy because
like I've done shrooms and [ __ ] and that
should have you tripping a little bit
but I heard PCP is like a whole nother
level of like that's pretty wild [ __ ]
like yeah especially when you towing
guns
give me like a describe what is that
likes hidden like for people because PCP
I feel like is something that is not
kind of
widely used nowadays like we don't hear
about like back in the 90s you know we
would hear Method Man yeah we would hear
Method Man and Wu-Tang talk about
smoking on Sherman [ __ ] but like
nowadays it's not a thing what is that
like to it's like what's that highlight
man uh
it's a pair no I have but a but uh
but a strong High you feel you feel
dominant
you know what I'm saying you feel
paranoid too
so uh
one time like I
I got off it because my mom was gonna
put me in the crazy house she was gonna
then she was acting she was tripping
talking about going to the PCP man
talking about she gonna play the police
on him if he sell me [ __ ] so that's how
I got off this [ __ ] my mama was tripping
and saying she gonna put me in a crazy
house where you had a bad episode yeah I
came home my feet was bleeding I was
crying I said horses and demons was
behind me it's a real story like I I had
kind of flat on the um on the River Road
and I had to walk like four miles home
in the dark
and uh while you were high yeah it had
to be a crazy walk yeah horses and
demons got behind me on my walk and I
ran home I was bleeding my mama crying
that's crazy so was that your worst
experience on that show I think about
like um the first Friday when Smokey
hits the PCP yeah and he ends up in the
chicken coop you know what I'm saying